If you were trapped in a school and forced
to kill your own teacher, what would you do?
This creature is not human,
and these kids are going to have to figure
out the most creative of ways to kill it
if they want to survive.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat
Koro-Sensei in Assassination's Classroom.
This creature is more than meets the eye.
This is class three,
and they only have one test that they need
to pass, kill their teacher,
readying their guns Nagisa here
and the rest of the class
shoot at Koro-Sensei
while he reads out the roll call
for the morning.
This creature has no known weakness,
and these students
are going to have to get pretty damn creative
if they want to beat it.
Class three, also known as the end
class, is the lowest of the low.
The students in this class
are the ones who failed of their final exams
to be able to proceed
into the next stage of high school.
Now this is their only chance at redemption.
The classroom is even separated
from the rest of the school
to further emphasize how damn stupid these
kids are on the very first day of class.
This strikingly yellow forearmed
creature known as Koro-Sensei, introduces
himself to the students.
The kids are confused by
what the hell is going on, so this government
official Karasuma explains that this creature
must be killed for the good of humanity.
This creature is responsible
for destroying the moon
and will destroy the Earth
in the same way by March of the next year.
This is top secret information, and only the
world's leaders know that the Earth is soon
going to blow up.
He tells the students to keep
this knowledge a secret.
Or else they'll face a global panic.
Suddenly, the man tries stabbing Koro-Sensei,
but his speed is unmatched.
Getting the better of him,
Koro-Sensei takes the time to groom his hair,
while the man explains a little bit
more about their new teacher, Koro-Sensei
speed maxes out and Mach 20, or roughly
25,000 kilometers per hour.
This means that he could easily
leave planet Earth before it gets destroyed.
To combat the creature,
the ministry has produced
a specially made B-BBEE pellets and knives,
which cause extreme damage
when used on Koro-Sensei.
OK, this guy is no joke.
This is Koro-Sensei,
also known as the world's
deadliest assassin and nicknamed the Reaper.
Now you might be wondering
what the hell this creature is.
His entire body is made from anti-matter,
which is a material in the universe
composed from antiparticles.
They have the same mass as ordinary matter,
but have an opposite charge.
If we were to see just how powerful
this stuff is, one gram of antimatter
could, in theory, produce
an explosion the size of a nuclear bomb.
Basically, this stuff is made
from highly unstable matter
and is volatile as hell,
and our teacher is made from this stuff.
And unfortunately, all of this insane
power comes with even more insane abilities.
This eight legged
teacher is immune to poisons,
can compress his entire body and energy
into a small, crystallized sphere
that is impervious to harm
even from a nuclear warhead.
He can regenerate severed limbs,
possesses superhuman senses and can travel up
to a speed of about Mach 20.
And this is just the tip of the iceberg
in terms of abilities.
Needless to say,
we're going to have to approach
this guy with extreme caution,
and these students
are about to realize that killing him
won't be nearly as easy as they hope.
Suddenly,
Koro-Sensei grabs the gun out of his hand
and detaches one of his arms, regrowing it
nearly instantly
to the shock of every student.
The man tells them to calm down
and reveals that Koro-Sensei here
made an agreement with the government
to never hurt the students.
This creature is like no other.
He tells the students
that he's decided to accept his death
as long as he gets to teach this school's
class three.
The government doesn't understand
chorus conditions,
but either way, the government
official informs them that they've put down
a ¥10 billion reward to whichever student
can assassinate the evil teacher.
From that point onwards, the kids begin
to realize the severity of the situation
and begin to train
even harder to kill Koro-Sensei.
Not only that, though,
Karasuma becomes their assistant teacher
and is joined by a professional assassin
known as Irina.
She's an absolute badass
and is great at her job, but not even Irina
can cause a dent in Koro-Sensei's armor.
Failing her mission,
she's demoted to a lowly English teacher
for the rest of the semester.
During lunch break, Nagisa here
shows his classmates a potential weakness
he found regarding the colors
that Koro-Sensei switches to and from.
Based on his emotions, his friends tell him
it's a worthless piece of information
and get ready to pull another assassination
attempt in the next class, looking worried.
Nagisa informs Koro-Sensei
that his work is already complete Koro-Sensei
then asks him to give him the work
so he can read it over.
But Nagisa here has something else in mind.
In a single motion, he tries to stab
Koro-Sensei, but he's too slow.
That's when Nagisa reveals
a bomb attached to his shirt, blowing up
and taking out the teacher once and for all.
Thrilled beyond belief, the kids
congratulate themselves on a job well done.
However, one of them notices
the leftover skin when suddenly
the teacher appears on the roof
and tells them that they've been outsmarted.
He reveals that he sheds his skin
once per month
and that the old skin took all of the damage,
realizing which students did it
Koro-Sensei changes colors
and tells the delinquents
that while he's made an agreement
to not hurt anyone in the classroom,
he can still kill every single one of them
outside of this room.
He tells them that they have a lot to learn,
and these students
are going to have to attempt even crazier
assassinations in the near future.
The next day, the students have Koro-Sensei
trapped in a net.
one of the students shows the teachers
that he put down a dirty magazine
exactly where the net was placed,
showing off his intelligence
when suddenly Koro-Sensei
spent the net over and over until it breaks.
When the students notice a lapse of focus.
They attempt to shoot the teacher,
but they're still too slow.
Koro-Sensei
simply swings himself onto the roof,
where he tells everyone that he'll be
doubling everyone's homework as punishment.
Okay, this guy is a horny bastard,
but then our very own anime writer.
Sorry, Tom,
and this is a case
example of why it's imperative
that we plan our moves more carefully
and that we should always have
a backup plan in place.
Because if we notice with Koro-Sensei,
he'll almost always be able to foil
our first plan, a assassination attempt.
But what if we had a contingent Plan B
and a Plan C and a Plan D?
You get my point.
We need to plan ahead enough
so that this anti-matter, education
loving monster doesn't know what hits him.
An example
of how we could have had a backup plan
after the initial assassination attempt
could have been in the form
of when we caught Koro-Sensei in the net.
After he got caught, he broke off
the basketball rim and landed on the roof.
Now, if these kids thought ahead in advance,
they could have gauged
that the distance
from where Koro-Sensei and the roof was
was close enough
that he could have made the jump
and that the roof, in comparison
to anywhere else,
was probably the safest platform to land on
and high enough that no other students
could come close to him if we planned ahead.
They could have tried
placing a bomb on the roof
or left some students in
and around the roof area, with the government
issued anti sensei weapons ready to go.
This is an example
of how having a Plan B in place
could have potentially worked,
and there are a myriad of ways
that the students can incorporate this level
of thinking into all of their future
assassination attempts.
That's when this cool looking kid
named Karma appears on the scene.
He and Koro-Sensei introduce themselves
by sharing a handshake
when suddenly Koro-Sensei
pulls his hand in pain.
Karma scolds him and reveals that he's
attached multiple knives to his hand.
This kid is smart,
and the only reason he's in this class
is because of his violent behavior
in the year before.
In the classroom, Koro-Sensei notices a dead
octopus on one of the tables outing himself.
Karma tells the teacher
he killed it, thinking it was him.
This angers Koro-Sensei,
who promises to show him
the extent of his abilities
by sticking a flaming hot takoyaki
into his mouth.
Later on, he and Nagisa
have a conversation about their new teacher
discussing who the hell he actually is.
Suddenly, Koro-Sensei shows up out of nowhere
to inform Karma that one of his goals is to
improve the skills of his assassin students,
adding that he's been taking good care of.
Based on today's events,
Karma asks him whether or not he'd
risk his life to save his student,
to which the teacher confirms he would.
Hearing this, the student whips out
a gun and jumps off the nearby cliff.
If Koro-Sensei comes to his rescue,
he'll be shot dead
by Karma's gun, and if he doesn't, he'll lose
his reputation as a teacher forever.
Without hesitation,
Koro-Sensei creates a massive spiderweb,
which breaks his fall
while keeping the student immobilized.
The students plants are ruined again, but
he promises that he'll kill him someday soon.
OK, these two guys here
failed in an epic way.
I bet Karma didn't think of the fact that if
Koro-Sensei tried to save him at max speed,
he would have been dead.
And if Karma did manage to kill Koro-Sensei,
he'd also die from the fall.
And to top that off,
Karma did and utilized Nagasaki at all
and just had him standing there
like a chump .
two dudes with one half baked plan.
And you know what?
I'll go out on a limb and say that
even if we added 100 more dudes to this plan,
the only thing we would have had
is an all out disaster.
Because yet again, these kids
failed to pick up on the breadcrumb clues
that our favorite teacher has left for us,
and that is his love for the obscene
portrayal of the opposite sex.
I would have swapped out
useless Nagisa for blond baddie
Irina and would have told her to use
her feminine ways to lure Koro-Sensei
into letting his guard down
for the sake of humanity.
Of course,
all they would have to do
is just flirt with him a little bit
and let his guard down before
blasting a hole right through his brain.
This way we would have stood a better chance
and we could have carried out this plan
with much better results.
Meanwhile, at the Ministry of Defense,
the government officials
worry about the fate of the Earth.
There's seemingly nothing
that can stop this creature,
and if nothing can be done,
the entire planet will be destroyed by March.
The order official scolds the teacher
for not being able to do anything,
but informs him that they'll be sending in a
transfer student as the next line of attack.
The next day, Karasuma introduces
a new student.
However, she's not like the others.
She's a female, a high.
Robot shaped like a box
whose sole purpose is to take out Koro-Sensei
the air robots suddenly
reveals a dozen machine guns from both sides
and start shooting at Koro-Sensei .
However, even the latest military technology
is no match for his speed after class,
one of the students scores the A.I.
for creating such a mess
with all of her bullets.
And that's when it begins
to calculate the percentage of success
for killing Koro-Sensei before graduation,
revealing a number of 90.4%
during the next class.
The students wrapped chains around the robot
to avoid cleaning up her bullets
every time she fires.
When classes
finished, Koro-Sensei approaches the A.I.
and tells her to try getting along
with her fellow classmates.
The AI is confused as to how to do that,
so Koro-Sensei reveals
that he's compiled data from all of Class
three students into these textbooks.
He unlocks her chains, and that night
the robot begins processing the information.
The next day, the air appears on everyone's
phones,
revealing that she made herself an app
to be able to communicate with each student
and support their assassination plans
in the classroom.
The students decide
to give her the name Rita,
and she soon becomes friendly
with everyone there.
The students mentioned that there will be
another transfer student coming in,
and that's when Koro-Sensei enters the room
for the morning roll call.
Suddenly,
a kid falls from the roof and immediately
sits down,
while a mysterious man draped in white enters
the classroom and scores the kid named Itona
for not coming in the proper way.
The man apologizes for his actions
and introduces himself as his guardian.
Itona
then gets up and grabs Karma by the hair,
telling him that he might be the strongest
in the class right now, but not anymore.
He confronts Koro-Sensei and states
that he is the only one worthy to beat
in this room, insisting that they face off
in this classroom straight after school,
setting up a makeshift arena.
The two face off
and the assassination attempt begins. Itokawa
feels tentacles of his own, which angers
Koro-Sensei on the very first exchange.
The teacher reverts to the classic roof
trick,
showing that Itona here is no pushover.
The little kid manages to cut off
Koro-Sensei's
tentacles, reducing his speed dramatically.
Now the probability of him dying from
the next attack has increased by 60%.
Koro-Sensei laughs it off
and the little kid goes to finish them off.
Suddenly, one of his tentacles is cut off
by an antisense a knife, reducing his powers,
wrapping Itona up in his own skin.
He throws the kid out of the classroom
and ends at the assassination.
The man in white takes him away,
promising to come back for revenge.
OK, Itona was the one foe who may have stood
a chance against Koro-Sensei
as he has tentacles of his own and incredible
physical abilities on par with him.
But he made the crucial mistake of doing
what Koro-Sensei expected him to do,
which was to play fair
because while they faced off fair and square,
Itona missed the opportunity to create
a coordinated attack with his schoolmates
and missed a chance where teamwork could have
prevailed over simply working alone.
Remember now
killing Koro-Sensei is the ultimate task,
and the fate of the world
rests on our shoulders.
I will note, though, that Itona managed
to successfully cut off a few, of Koro-Sensei
tentacles, reducing his speed by over 40%
during this crucial moment
where he was on the floor more injured
and hindered than he's ever been before.
So far,
all of their attacks have been very isolated.
But can you imagine if all 30 of them
attacked Koro-Sensei during this Face-Off?
Because if there's one thing
that likely won't work against our battle
hardened teacher,
it's playing alone and fair and square.
These kids need to start playing dirty
and get it together
if they want to even stand up minuscule
of a chance
of fighting against this creature
with godlike powers.
After Class Nagisa
and the other students as Koro-Sensei
why he decided to teach Class three,
he responds by saying
he made a promise to someone a long time ago,
but he can't tell them who it is.
The only way to know is to kill him,
so Nagisa asks him what they can do
to improve their assassination chances.
Koro-Sensei suggests
that they take weekend classes
aiming at the assassination
training camp during camp, Nagisa notes down
a number of weaknesses he sees, such
as his limited efficiency with after images.
Meanwhile, Karasuma begins analyzing each
student strengths and weaknesses for combat.
However,
he has nothing to say about Nagasaki.
Later on, the boys of the class begin
a mission of their own,
creeping their way into the girls bathroom.
Meanwhile,
the girls talk with Irina about her love life
when suddenly Koro-Sensei
appears from behind,
he dashes out of the room before
answering questions about his own love life
while the girls chase him away.
The boys realize what's going on and decide
to chase after as well, leaving Nisar behind.
Suddenly,
Koro-Sensei pops up in Karasuma room.
The man shows in the results
from the assassination
training camp, which disappoint Koro-Sensei,
saying that it's still not good enough.
After training camp, a new PE teacher
introduces himself as Karasuma substitute
and gives out free food
for the first lesson Karasuma and Koro-Sensei
look on while he tells the creature
that they have to find new ways
to assassinate him.
The new teacher is instantly popular
with the students.
However, looks are deceiving and this nice
guy is more than meets the eye, That night,
Irina interrupts cross-match reveal
that she knows all about him and the teachers
history,
telling him about their intense rivalry.
She tells him that he has a history
of getting good and fast
results out of his students. However,
it comes at a cost.
The next day, the teacher gets the kids to do
laps around the schoolyard.
When one of the girls
collapsed in front of him,
she tells him that she can't do this
any longer and prefers Karasuma.
Most classes angered.
The teacher violently slaps the girl before
being stopped by Karasuma himself.
He tells him that this is his way
of discipline to prove his way of teaching
is superior.
The teacher asked Karasuma
to pick one of his kids to fight.
He will fight bare handed
and if the student manages to even touch him
once he'll concede defeat and admit
he's a worst teacher.
However, the PE teacher adds one more thing
the knife they use will be real.
Karasuma gathers the students, putting
the onus on Nagisa to fight in his place.
Nagisa agrees, and the fight begins.
Nagisa are slowly inches towards him,
pushing him to the ground
and placing the knife on his neck.
The student wins and the PE teacher promises
that he'll be back for more. OK?
While this may seem like sweet victory,
this means so much more.
This is just the tip of something they could
and most likely
will become a whole
lot more serious in the future.
The PE teacher was no doubt a self-righteous
prick to abuse that girl student,
but what Karasuma
and the whole class failed to realize
was that that PE teacher was humiliated
and power hungry based on how he
handled his role
as an authoritative member of the school
and the fact that he just vowed that
he'd be back.
Can only mean that
the next time he comes back to fight,
it'll likely be on his own terms
and without any forms of rules to go by,
which means we can't let him get to
that point.
Nagisa the girl who got slapped
or even yellow cephalopod, Koro-Sensei
himself of all, should have recognized
that slap to begin with was illegal
and with corporal punishment
in Japan being illegal,
they should have used that PE Teachers
Act of rule defiance as grounds to sue him
and get him off of the grounds to begin with.
Not that that would stop Koro-Sensei
if he truly decided to kill him, though,
which would not be a bad option.
Though if we're not going to kill him,
maybe we should go to the legal route
because in a nation that prizes conformity
and obedience to authority.
If the students don't act now,
then they'll further encourage
this behavior,
which will lead to more future problems.
And we already have our hands full
with trying to take on Koro-Sensei.
We don't need any more problems
or distractions headed our way.
The next day,
one of the students asks Koro-Sensei
to drink a poison she made suddenly his face
because to transform and turn white.
However, it doesn't work.
During the next few days,
Koro-Sensei plays around with the kids,
showing off new and improved powers
to the students.
The students begin to get angry
and have self-doubt, telling Koro-Sensei
that he's too good to be assassinated.
This angers the teacher beyond belief,
who tells them that they don't have
what it takes yet to be an assassin,
and he asks all of the class
to gather in the schoolyard
with everyone's attention now on him.
He asks the students
whether or not they really want to kill him.
He asks the professional assassin if she only
plans one attack for an assassination.
She tells him that a proper assassination
with detailed backup plans for any possible
scenario is a must.
Moving to Karasuma,
he asks him if the first strike
is the only important one when using a knife.
He responds by saying that the first strike
is likely to be dodged, so follow up
strikes are even more important
than the first quarter.
Sensei tells the kids
that is the utmost of importance
that they continue studying
in case he disappears or, even worse, dies.
That's when he jets off circling
right back onto the schoolyard
with a giant military weapon.
He tells the class that if he doesn't
see any improvement in the students,
he will simply vanish.
He reminds them of the poison incident,
telling them they need to be more deceptive
if they want to have a successful
assassination.
A successful assassin is well rounded
in every sense of the word, a word
that they'll soon
find out the importance of very soon.
Later
that day, Koro-Sensei tells them of a goal
that they must achieve for the end of term
exams.
Each student
who receives a top score in a subject
will be allowed
to destroy one of his tentacles.
Losing even
one tentacle will drastically decrease
his speed and reduce his ability to create
after images, making their assassination
attempt a whole lot easier.
Excited beyond belief.
The classic gets to studying
after hearing the good news.
OK, if I'm the snotty nosed kids, then
I'm not sure what the hell they're doing.
They got to study Koro-Sensei
down to his daily bowel habits.
This is a case example
of not putting in the extra work to study
after school hours as well as during.
These kids should be following
Koro-Sensei around the clock everywhere
he goes through town as best as they can.
Observing him at school
only tells them one side of the whole story,
and this is something
that the class should take into account
if they want to have any chances
of killing him at all.
We should round up the entire class
and get them to help us, and above all,
we need to make sure
that we don't get caught in the staff room.
Karasuma tells them that the classes
academic skills have drastically improved.
Koro-Sensei agrees,
saying that the students need to.
Fit, not just physically but mentally,
if they want to assassinate him
later on course and say surprises
one of the students
and tells her that he plans to improve her
English skills through first hand experience.
Suddenly,
he grabs and sends her around the world
to learn everything
the world has to offer before they know it.
The day of their exam results have arrived.
Announcing the students scores,
they realized that
with the amount of top scores,
they have the ability to cut off
six tentacles.
The students are thrilled
and they get to work, making the final trap
to assassinate Koro-Sensei once and for all.
That night, the class watches the fireworks
from the roof, wondering
if they'll really be able to kill Koro-Sensei
the next day.
Suddenly, Koro-Sensei himself shows up,
wishing the students
luck in their assassination attempt.
Now the day has finally arrived.
The students get their antisense
a weapons ready for the assassination
and reveal a massive trap
with the sole purpose
of killing their teacher.
The kids tell, Koro-Sensei
said, that they plan to cut off his tentacles
and slow down his movements afterwards,
caging him inside water to finish him off.
Surprised Koro-Sensei asks the students
how they knew about his weakness to water,
and Karma reveals
that he found after due to him bloating up
when the weather was humid and rainy .
On the count of three,
the talking ends and the action begins.
The students begin shooting at Koro-Sensei,
cutting off his tentacles.
Next, throw as much water
as humanly possible onto the creature.
In the midst of the chaos, two mystery men
shoot a sensei with anti-sensei
bullets, creating a massive explosion
which shocks all of the students.
OK, it seems as though these students,
unlike the previous times, actually
put some pristine thought and effort
into their latest assassination attempt,
which honestly is quite
a refreshing surprise.
But it still sucks. Hear me out.
As we know with Koro-Sensei, nothing with him
is as it seems, and I would have used
all of my cards in our final assassination
attempt that was taking place.
Because if we remember, Nagisa
was taking notes and noted down the behaviors
and patterns of Koro-Sensei.
And since this is the final assassination
attempt,
I would have used the other
two known weaknesses of Koro-Sensei.
first, the antisense a material
and second some questionable magazines.
Because why in the world
would the kids set up
this perfect assassination contraption
and not to use every trick in their book
to defeat Koro-Sensei, for example, wrapping
Koro-Sensei up in anti-sensei material
like this guy had on earlier before chopping
all of his tentacles and not just six.
Because any way you slice it,
the only way to fight back
against this overpowered balloon head
octopus would be to fight dirty.
Now I may be an expert on pretty much
everything I know.
I don't care what you say.
YouTube comments, but I'm definitely
an expert on telling a bunch of kiddos.
Their plan is not exactly
all the way thought through confused
the students awake to see Koro-Sensei gone,
and they can't believe their eyes.
Suddenly, they see him in a shallow puddle.
Now, in the shape of a sphere,
Koro-Sensei reveals that this fear that he's
in is crystallized high density condensed
energy, meaning he can't be affected by water
or anti sensei substances.
Karma attempts to shoot him,
but it's no use in this form.
Koro-Sensei can't be hurt.
However, the form will only last around
24 hours.
Karma suggests
that they cage him up in a pool
full of antisense a material,
but Koro-Sensei tells him he'll just
explode again,
breaking the cage and setting himself free.
The students are disappointed,
and suddenly some of them begin to pass out.
That's when a jeep comes rolling in and the
PE teacher jumps out with his squad lackeys.
He's back for revenge,
and none of the students
could have predicted him being this petty.
The teacher reveals that the students
are passing out from a toxin that they drank
and that they only have three days
left to live once infected,
and he shows
that the only antidotes are with him.
This is diabolical as hell,
and these kids have no idea what hit them.
But before we can address this fully,
we should understand
the psychological response
to the act of fainting,
which can come about due
to the stimulation of the vagus nerve.
This nerve is responsible for the regulation
of internal organ functions
such as digestion, heart failure, respiratory
failure, as well as vasomotor activity,
which refers to the actions
upon a blood vessel which alter its diameter.
This is a reason that can cause the heart to
slow and blood pressure to drop drastically.
However, it's important to note
that not all losses of
consciousness are related to the vagus nerve.
Now, the cold, hard fact of the matter is
is that we can't get rid of the poison
from our systems
if we don't know what poison is being used.
But the PE teacher is the only one
who knows what poison it is,
and he's the only one around here
with the cure on him.
However, the PE teacher made one
final mistake in his threatening execution.
He stated that the poison delivered to the
students will kill them within three days.
That means we actually have time
to kick his ass
and sad to say,
but the price of all of these students
is worth the possession of Koro-Sensei
not being in their hands.
Because, let's face it, our yellow octopus
friend at this point is basically a kid's
toy sized bee 41 hydrogen bomb,
which means we can't afford to hand him over.
And like I said, even if they don't make.
It no kid is above dying for Koro-Sensei
because the world is safer if he's in our
possession than the bad guys.
Sometimes you've got to make harsh choices
in life.
Kids furious at the incident with Nagasaki,
he tells the teachers, only
to give them the antidotes in exchange
for his arch nemesis, Karasuma Approaches
Nagisa,
who is holding Koro-Sensei in his hands?
Koro-Sensei
doesn't believe that the teacher is truthful,
telling him
that something is off about the negotiation.
Suddenly, a tentacle appears out of nowhere,
attacking Nagasaki and Karasuma
climbing up on the Jeep is Itona.
Who's gained complete control over his
tentacles, wanting to be the strongest?
He chases after Nagisa and Karma,
who is still holding Koro-Sensei in a ball.
Meanwhile, the PE teacher
laughs at their misfortune, saying that
he'll be the one with the ¥10 billion
while he gets back into the Jeep.
The teachers look on helpless with no way
to harm the man because of the antidote.
Still on the run
chorus, Sensei tells Nagisa
not to worry about the others
and only focus on stopping Itona.
Meanwhile,
the class is treating the unwell students
who are currently in critical condition.
However, while they might be in the school,
they're not as safe as they might think.
Nagisa and Karma continue
the chase up an electrical tower
when suddenly a tentacle slashes the ladder
they're climbing on, separating Nagisa
and Karma to free his hands.
Nagisa throws Koro-Sensei to Karma
but assume confronted by Itona,
he tries to run, but he can't escape.
He's restrained by the tentacles
and uses Koro-Sensei to hit him away.
Using the beams he continues to climb while
avoiding the tentacles until getting hit down
and injured.
Nagisa manages to make it onto the platform
while Itona slowly walks towards karma.
The boy admits his defeat and tells Deltona
he'll hand Koro-Sensei over to him.
That's when he kicks the ball
over to Nagasaki, making Itona even angrier.
He demands that they give him what he wants,
but his powers are about to disappear
because suddenly it starts to rain, heavily
causing your toner to cover up in fear.
Nagata
hugs the boy for giving him on the spot.
Koro-Sensei realizes that the students
decided on this date for the assassination
because of the heavy rain.
He tells you tonight
that he should stay in class
in order to become a better assassin
and asks if he would like to join.
Suddenly,
the boys get a text from a fellow classmate
telling them that something bad has happened
back at the school.
Arriving at the schoolyard,
Nagisa is greeted by the teacher
who demands that he hands over the sphere.
He has one of the females captured and plans
to bury her in cement if Nagisa declines
the offer.
He continues to push Nagisa
to hand Koro-Sensei over
reminding him
that he has the antidote to the virus.
But to the teacher's surprise, Nagisa pleads
for him to be the one to kill Koro-Sensei.
However, the teacher doesn't agree
and stomps Nagisa as head down to the floor.
Nagisa smiles and hands over Koro-Sensei.
However, it's a fake
and the teacher takes out a ball.
That's when the rest of Class
three comes out from the school building,
all with guns in hand.
Moments later, the PE teacher and his lackeys
are restrained with no way of getting out.
Koro-Sensei congratulates
the students on their hard work, and the A.I.
robot reveals that
she's already found out the formula
for the antidote, meaning everyone is safe.
Looking above, the students
see government vehicles coming to the rescue.
What to do? Weebs. Dom and Albert here.
so Albert, tell me,
what did you think of Assasination Classroom?
Well, first off,
there's a reason why we did
the live action movie and not the anime,
and you can find out when to pin
comment down below.
So my main problem with the live action
movie was that it
try to adapt the anime too much.
What I mean is that the story structure
is all over the place
and each point
are disconnected to each other.
But the visual effects are really good.
The characters are funny,
and Koro-Sensei is a giant perv.
Koro-Sensei is a horny bastard.
But here's the thing the guy never dies.
I don't know what the writers are smoking
when they came up with this dude,
but props to them
because you just can't beat them.
You really can't. But overall, great story.
A lot of heart. And yeah.
Back to the show in the government facility,
Karasuma tells everyone
they've developed a shelter to safe earth.
Looking towards the monitor,
Koro-Sensei gives the class a final message,
congratulating them on their progress.
All the while being buried,
an anti sensei bullets on the count of three.
The government announces that Koro-Sensei,
the destroyer of the Moon, has been killed,
leaving the students in tears.
Suddenly, a yellow hand pops up out of
nowhere, revealing the message to be untrue.
Koro-Sensei is still alive
and well now, back for the second term.
The kids continue their assassination
attempts.
However, there's a much bigger threat
waiting for them in the future.
And if you don't want to get wrecked
by non-suspicious looking yellow tentacles
and like comment, let us know what you liked
and of course, didn't like it.
Don't forget check out.
How to be playlist down below.